this is so exciting to me because I feel
like I grew up watching you and now here
you are how are you feeling right now as
we're celebrating the premiere of the
hill it's finally here you know it's
crazy it's been a wild ride for the last
six seven months so you know it's really
fun for us to like put that behind us
and come out and hang out and yeah we're
looking forward to this what was the
highlight for you of filming truly
connecting with people during filming
and bonding because you know it's a
crazy experience and I think that once
you finally like make that bond and you
kind of know who your people are that's
a nice feeling like you've had such a
wild past few years what are we going to
learn about you well well all sorts of
stuff I mean I certainly have and you
know the show is just really about us
bonding and having fun and you do learn
some stuff about me I don't think they
you know I definitely talk about my life
and what's been going on and then it's a
lot about us interacting together so
we'll see what ends up in the show I
suppose I'm not really the person to
tell you how they edit it together but
romantic personal life are we gonna see
you on dates are we gonna see you don't
even I don't even want to talk about the
romantic thing we'll see I mean yes
there's some of that going on and then
the girls yeah you'll have to watch to
find out what are you looking for in a
partner you know I love men who make me
laugh and are adventurous and travel a
lot and are very like understanding of
my career in my life and like I just I
think it's like everyone you want a best
friend to come home to yeah it's been
ten years since you starred in a TV show
I think it was a beautiful life in 2009
sure what would it take to get you back
on my TV screen acting every week well
um you'll see in the show I'm going on
auditions and they're gonna back out
there and I've been doing that and I've
been developing stuff so I'm just not
yeah I'm just not sure what it'll be yet
but but yeah I'm definitely gaming for
that
I feel like you are kind of the reason
why all this happened because though
seeing them ago to beach and on the
hills have any of your old OC co-stars
reached out congratulated you on this
new chapter open to a couple of them
like you know I talked to Peter
Gallagher quite a lot I talked to like
you know some of the moms but yeah not
really everybody's off doing their own
shows and their own things and this has
moved so fast and we've been so busy
that I don't think that's really like to
do with anything other than the fact
that we're all crazy busy